all right everybody
let's go ahead and start to shut up
we're gonna jump right in on the one
subject that brings me a little bit of
joy in toledo where i find myself
currently trapped
taking down my rival miles now i had a
pretty good idea
thinking maybe we could hack into his
tesla how hard would that be i know it's
possible
you think you guys could do that are you
guys the kind of nerds that are good at
computers or are you the kind of nerds
that smell bad and
wear capes
uh you know what um let's go ahead and
put a pin in that because a cute girl
who actually meets my standards has
swiped right on me and i don't know if
you guys know what that means but
basically it just means that it's
it's bang time is it going to be
happening here
in front of us no anthony it's not gonna
be happening in front of you a little
freak
no we're gonna go get a drink guys gotta
say i got a really good feeling about
this one can i
get some get some that's my girl
all right um see you dudes
now boarding for new york city
[Music]
[Applause]
if it's on my license you know they're
not going to want to save me
they're going to want to harvest my
organs that's what they want they want
myself
yeah and i am not gonna die on the table
so some drunk slob can get my liver no
no that's not fair
no you should have your liver it's very
good it's pristine yeah exactly
so you want to head up to your place
i really like you jack i just i just
want to get to know you a little bit
better
yeah sure more dates
i'm around cool good night good night
wake up we're in toledo time to go to
work
you